la pandémie de kobe 19 nous a fait
réaliser l'importance de l'accès aux
données en temps réel pour mieux
comprendre et gérer la crise
pour faciliter leurs travaux les
chercheurs universitaires réclament un
meilleur accès à ses données publiques
en santé au québec c'est encore une
course à obstacles comme l'expliquent
mon collègue henri bernard chaque jour
la plupart des gestes composent génère
une donnée compris en santé un test pour
la kfw d'un vaccin
une hospitalisation une consultation en
examen une prescription des données
précieuses qui s'accumulent chaque jour
il y aurait effectivement mine d'or de
données qui à mon avis je vous exploitez
n'est pas valorisé une montagne de
données mais cette montagne là en fait
elle est très dispersé
[Musique]
la plupart des informations sur les
soins que vous recevez en santé sont
colligés dans des entités séparées
souvent étanche hôpital clc d'armes à 6
régie de l'assurance-maladie ministère
de la santé c'est un peu comme si vous
faisiez affaire avec deux banques
différentes l'une n'est pas
nécessairement au courant des
transactions vous faites avec l'autre
d'ailleurs comme les banques les
organisations du réseau de la santé oms
la responsabilité des données qu'elles
ont entre les mains
elles doivent protéger les
renseignements personnels qu'elles
contiennent c'est normal c'est la loi
l'ennui au québec du moins ce qu à
vouloir protéger à tout prix les données
publiques en santé on a rendu leur accès
très restrictif par moment quasi
impossible même aux chercheurs
universitaires de beaucoup des farc
doivent être mis pour assembler ces
données là donc c'est un parcours du
combattant pour plusieurs chercheurs de
france ce travail c'est beaucoup
d'efforts investis
philippe debry professeur et chercheur à
l'université laval
impliqué dans la valorisation des
données en santé il veut nous aider à
comprendre quels problèmes cela peut
poser quand on ne souhaite obtenir des
données sans avoir de passer par le
consentement des participants
on doit s'adresser là comme son accès
mais souvent on va s'intéresser aussi à
la donne et qui serait ailleurs dans le
réseau donc elle a donné dans les
cabinets de médecins de famille de la
donne et où ce temps les centres
hospitaliers et les mécanismes pour
accéder à ces données là elles sont
différents
c'est un fait comme s'il fallait pour
chaque demande s'adresser à un guichet
où un comptoir différent on comprend que
ces allers retours entre les chercheurs
et les institutions qui détiennent ou
autorise le partage des données et long
cela peut s'étirer sur des mois un an ou
plus
[Musique]
tout à fait et l'on a parlé seulement
des embûches administratives juridiques
pour accéder la donner mais pour avoir
des jeux de données qui sont propres il
faut procéder à certaines opérations de
nettoyage sur les données en brie donné
aberrante et ça aussi c'est un effort
considérable
les chercheurs sont aussi soumis à des
conditions strictes d'utilisation des
données
c'est compréhensible mais certaines de
ces conditions sont parfois
contre-productive je pense que ce qui
nuit dans ce processus là aussi c'est
que la commission d'accès vont nous
demander de détruire les données une
fois que projet est terminé
donc beaucoup d'efforts qui ont été
investis pour constituer des jeux de
données qui sont riches
ultimement pour être détruits à cause
des contraintes pour accéder aux données
publiques en santé
certains projets de recherche ne verront
pas le jour cela limite aussi
l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle en santé pour exploiter des
masses de données et faire émerger de
nouvelles pistes de recherche
il ya certains paradoxes l'équipe est
cruel de 202 du fait qu'on consomme et
l'intelligence artificielle de l'avant
mais d'un autre côté on note certaines
embûches quand on veut constituer deux
des grands jeux de données qui sont
l'essence même lot de sorties sienne en
plusieurs coques cette montagne de 2
est sous utilisé selon les chercheurs
c'est un peu l'équivalent de laisser
dormir de l'argent comptant au fond d'un
coffre fort accéder aux données en temps
portant clairement dans un temps pas
d'émission est extrêmement important on
le vul à son veut tracer les contacts si
on le fait trois semaines après le
diagnostic
ça fonctionne pas donc d'avoir une
meilleure fluidité dans les données
points
c'est essentiel dans un mémoire déposé
en septembre dernier sur la révision de
la loi québécoise sur les renseignements
personnels
même le scientifique en chef du québec
milite pour que soit reconnu
l'importance de l'utilisation dé devenir
des fins de recherche ou sein de
l'appareil gouvernemental
étant donné la difficulté d'accéder à la
donner au québec et certains chercheurs
se sont tournés vers l'ontario pour
répondre à leurs questions de recherche
l'institut des sciences cliniques
évaluative là ici s est un organisme qui
existe depuis plus de 25 ans en ontario
une sorte de comptoir d'accès qui permet
de faire le pont entre les chercheurs et
les données publiques en santé c'est le
genre de modèle que les chercheurs
aimeraient voir se reproduire au québec
maintenir des efforts qui sont faits
dans ce sens là mais selon rue on est
encore loin du but ultime en accusation
de la donner par les chercheurs pour
s'enrichir personnellement c'est pas
pour pourvoir à des compagnies
c'est pour améliorer les soins pour
améliorer le système de santé donc de
vouloir trop protéger les données peut
avoir des effets pervers ou ou les soins
ultima peuvent être affectés il faut
peser le pour et le contre
et justement trouver le compromis idéal
cette combinaison gagnante entre la
protection des renseignements personnels
et l'utilisation des données massives en
santé
c'est à trouver mais le temps semble
montrer que le québec devra tôt ou tard
des serrer la vis qui permettent un
accès plus large une utilisation
optimale de ces données